la economía en francés 24 ya está
conmigo en el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge félix mañana iniciamos en la
región dando un panorama económico de
los países de américa latina jorge así
es raúl ya es que bueno y los problemas
de la pandemia la crisis en la cadena de
suministro la convulsión política que se
vive en la región e inclusive el cambio
climático están haciendo que las
principales economías de nuestra américa
latina pues viva índice altos en la
inflación según la comisión económica
para américa latina y el caribe cepal la
región registró una media de inflación
general del 72 por ciento en 2021 esto
sin contar los países con inflación
crónica como argentina y surinam y
venezuela brasil méxico chile y colombia
tuvieron un comportamiento superior al
techo del rango de meta de los bancos
centrales pero en argentina y venezuela
se siguen viendo los factores
estructurales que tenían desde antes de
la pandemia el organismo indica que
américa latina es la región más afectada
por la pandemia y en 2021 creció 62 por
ciento pero prevén que en 2022 estará
marcado por las asimetrías entre países
y una desaceleración por la
incertidumbre escuchemos un poco que
dicen los analistas al respecto
uno de los riesgos que se nos vienen a
toda latinoamérica pero en general a
todos los países emergentes aparece
programas emergentes dice que el
producto inflacionario no sólo se está
en latinoamérica sino en todo el mundo
desarrollado allí
ese hecho permite anticipar aumentos en
tasas de interés en eeuu en europa que
van a generar aumentos en las tasas de
interés de equilibrio en los mercados
internacionales eso sumado al hecho de
quién
o los países han incurrido en deudas
crecientes y que en muchos países
colombia es un caso claro y siguen
teniendo un déficit fiscal importante
hace que
la sostenibilidad de la deuda
y las posibilidades de un manejo fiscal
prudente
sean más difíciles jorge y brasil
ofrecerá residencias extranjeros que
trabajen remotamente para otro país así
que esto puede ser una muy buena noticia
para los nómadas digitales y es
consecuencia de todo esto que ha
acelerado de alguna forma la pandemia el
consejo nacional de inmigración de
brasil anunció que su iniciativa busca
facilitar esta vía extranjeros que
tengan contratos de trabajo para
empresas de otros países y puedan
trabajar de forma remota según la
resolución el beneficiario no puede
tener ningún tipo de contrato o vínculo
de empleo con empresas de brasil los
extranjeros interesados raúl en este
tipo de visas podrán obtener la
residencia por un plazo inicial de un
año que puede ser renovado por un
período igual continua para el gobierno
brasileño representa una oportunidad de
seguir la tendencia mundial de empleo y
al mismo tiempo impulsar el turismo y el
ingreso de renta el solicitante debe
ganar al menos 1500 dólares obtener en
su saldo bancario unos 18 mil dólares
para poder aplicar a este beneficio
vamos entonces a europa jorge porque
cientos empresas enfrentan el aumento de
los costos
y ahí el aumento de los costos en las
piezas los materiales el transporte y
hasta la energía así como las crecientes
exigencias salariales comienzan a
impactar en los clientes y sobre todo en
el precio de los consumidores por
ejemplo en republica checa a los
propietarios de negocios enfrentan las
mismas presiones inflacionistas que el
resto del mundo pero se suma a un fuerte
crecimiento salarial con tasas de
desempleo entre las más bajas de la
unión europea el grupo lácteo checo
mabeta aumento los precios de esos
productos un 10% más o menos a este mes
en ese país la inflación superará el 9
por ciento a principios de 2022 según el
banco central lo mismo ocurre en hungría
y también polonia escuchemos por
supuesto también nos ha afectado el
rápido aumento de los precios de la
energía y otros costos de producción
como los materiales de embalaje el
combustible los servicios y la mano de
obra y por ello nos hemos visto
obligados a aumentar nuestros precios
una media del 10% en enero jorge y
repasamos los indicadores económicos de
asia y también de europa bueno las
acciones asiáticos keith cayeron con
fuerza
con los inversores nerviosos por la
posibilidad de un conflicto militar en
ucrania y prevea la reunión de la
reserva federal de eeuu en europa las
acciones se estabilizaron este martes
después de su peor venta desde junio de
2020 y vamos ahora con la cifra del día
que tiene que ver con boquilla así que
son 200 millones de dólares esa fue la
venta aproximada del catálogo musical de
bob dylan a sonny group según la revista
estadounidense variety graciasjorge por
toda esa información económica nos vemos
más adelante con la economía por ahora
vamos a ver nuestro reportaje el día
[Música]